depuis la semaine dernière également une
vaste campagne de dépistage a démarré
dans les lycées franciliens c'est à
l'initiative de la région et de l'agencé
régionale de santé d'île de france
quatre établissements sont concernés
dans les yvelines dont jules ferry à
versailles le 27 novembre dernier
environ 250 tests antigénique ont été
réalisés avec des lycéens et personnels
volontaires
cette démarche expérimentale vise à
préparer une action de dépistage
généralisé dans les lycées qui aura lieu
après les fêtes de fin d'année les
propos recueillis sur place par bixente
mais rien senti steban c'était une
démarche sur les canons se porter
volontaire parce que on se rend compte
qu'il ya quand même une inquiétude de la
part des étudiants de la part des
personnels sur cette question de
l'accueil vide et donc c'était
l'occasion de proposer un dispositif qui
permet de rassurer tout le monde
l'idée c'est de pouvoir lancer une des
pistes âge massif de tous les personnels
et les élèves qui sont volontaires pour
pouvoir venir se faire dépister par test
antigénique après les vacances scolaires
après toute cette période épidémique
qu'on l'a connu à pourvoir un petit peu
qu'elle ait la circulation du virus